there's a proverb that says behind every
great man is a great woman that is
certainly true of spacex elon musk may
be the most recognizable face of his
aerospace company but his right hand
woman is gwyn shotwell hi everybody
shotwell is the president and chief
operating officer of spacex she manages
the day-to-day operations and the growth
of the firm in other words she's in
charge of selling rockets and dealing
with elon musk unlike a lot of spacex
employees who grew up fascinated by
rockets she wasn't when she was five in
her neurosurgeon father gathered the
family around a tv to watch the apollo
11 moon landing she found it boring she
wasn't interested in space at the time
she didn't watch star trek as a kid
still fate somehow put her on a path
that led to spacex shotwell grew up in
libertyville illinois a small town north
of chicago the middle child of two
sisters she had a mechanical mind in the
third grade she asked her mom how car
engines worked so her mother an artist
bought her a book about cars in high
school she was a cheerleader and played
varsity basketball but wasn't sure what
she wanted to do after graduating her
mom wanted gwen to be an engineer and
dragged her to a women's engineering
event which would change the course of
her life while there shotwell admired
the female mechanical engineer on the
panel and the beautiful suit she wore i
loved her suit
and not not joke i'm not exaggerating
the years have not uh have not changed
this story i asked her about her suit
and what she did and she owned her own
company she really inspired me and that
day i said okay mom you can get off my
back i will be a mechanical engineer
shotwell didn't have to look far to find
a great school a half hour's drive from
her hometown was northwestern university
it was the only school she applied to
she chose northwestern because it was
strong in disciplines in addition to
engineering which suited her because she
didn't want to be seen as a nerd little
did she know how cool geeks would become
shotwell was one of only three women out
of 36 mechanical engineering undergrads
but she said she never had any issues
being in what was still largely
considered a man's world she did have a
problem landing an internship one summer
at a heating ventilation and air
conditioning design company the boss was
impressed with her resume but when he
spoke to her over the phone for the
first time this is how she said the
conversation went as published in
northwestern universities magazine the
guy said you're a girl i said well of
course i'm a girl he says well you can't
possibly do this job there will be heavy
lifting i said i lift weights i'm an
athlete and he basically said you can't
have this job and hung up it was so
blatant what a jerk
she graduated with a bachelor of science
in mechanical engineering in 1986 and
interviewed with ibm on the day of the
space shuttle challenger disaster a
mission which had garnered a lot of
attention because a teacher was on board
the tragedy shook shotwell she didn't
get the job at ibm but she was hired by
chrysler as part of a program that
groomed graduates from management she
did everything at chrysler from
rebuilding engines to working alongside
engineers who designed the cars but she
didn't find the work interesting so she
left and went to grad school also at
northwestern after getting her masters
in applied mathematics she ran into a
former teaching assistant who happened
to be working at the aerospace
corporation in california he suggested
she do the same so she applied and was
hired as a thermal analyst which
included running models on
supercomputers of the space shuttle
heating in real time and feeding that
information to nasa but this work didn't
excite her either she was itching to go
out and create something after a decade
at the aerospace corporation she moved
over to microcosm a low-budget rocket
builder where she became a director
focused on selling services to the
government in other firms she honed the
business skills that would later be
crucial to the success of spacex how did
she land at spacex
according to the book liftoff by eric
berger a colleague of shotwells at
microcosm engineer hans koenigsmann was
about to leave to join spacex which was
then a little-known startup shotwell
took him out for a going-away lunch and
then dropped him off at his new digs
konigsman offered to show her around and
that's when shotwell met musk musk
talked about his ideas for cutting the
cost of space travel by building his own
rockets in-house shawwell was impressed
by his ambition to shake up the
aerospace industry she too was
frustrated by the lack of innovation she
mentioned that he should hire someone
dedicated to sales to find a customer
for spacex's first rocket the falcon one
musk took her advice to heart and later
offered her the job though she didn't
say yes right away she already had a
stable job two young children to look
after and only just divorced her first
husband when she gave a virtual
commencement address at her alma mater
in 2021 she elaborated on her difficult
decision it seemed so risky for me
personally to join this little startup
in an industry where none had ever
succeeded
at the time i was a part-time single
mother and this was just too far out of
my comfort zone i was driving on the
freeway here in la when it finally hit
me i was being a total idiot
who cares if i tried this job and either
i failed or the company failed
what i recognized at that moment was
that it was the trying part that was the
most important try that risky thing be a
part of something exciting i don't want
to imagine what my life and career would
be like had i said no i'm sure i would
have been fine but i would not have been
a part of this amazing company working
alongside such extraordinary people
not taking that job would have been the
fail a shotwell joined spacex as the
vice president of sales in 2002. she was
employee number 11. there's queen at her
queue today some call her the secret
sauce behind the company's success
because of her engineering expertise
business know-how and connections in the
industry which helped her land lucrative
contracts after spacex launched the
falcon 1 into orbit on its fourth
attempt in 2008 she negotiated a 1.6
billion contract with nasa to deliver
cargo and supplies to astronauts at the
international space station that deal
saved spacex from bankruptcy and in 2013
she was reportedly instrumental in
securing a 20-year lease of launch pad
39a at the kennedy space center the
historic launch pad previously used by
the apollo moon missions and space
shuttle flights despite her success at
the right hand of musk it's not easy
working for him as some former employees
at his other company tesla have attested
an ex-manager there told business
insider it's a culture in which if you
don't have a solution to a problem and
you don't have that problem resolved
within a few days or a week or two
you're gone so it's better to keep your
mouth shut on the other hand shotwell
believes musk actually drives you to do
your best work saying at a ted
conference when elon says something you
have to pause and not immediately blurt
out well that's impossible or there's no
way we're gonna do that so you zip it
think about it and you find ways to get
that done
[Applause]
spacex was the first private company to
transport american astronauts to the iss
next it plans to take humans to the moon
and later to mars on a fully reusable
rocket named starship we want to make
the world a better place and our
contribution there is to develop systems
that will take people to other planets
kind of proliferate the human species
and i know that sounds crazy doesn't
sound very businessy but frankly that's
why we're in business
over the past two decades shotwell has
helped grow spacex from 10 employees to
10 000 from zero revenue to billions of
dollars annually musk and shotwell may
appear to be polar opposites he can be
awkward at times she's smooth and all
smiles yet they have a shared ambition
to get things done
if you've been inspired by shotwell's
story and want to follow in her
footsteps a solid background in
engineering and mathematics is crucial
my sponsor brilliant can help plus it's
free to sign up brilliant is a website
and app to help you really learn
something by jumping right into it one
of brilliant's newest courses is on
scientific thinking where a game of
snooker can help you explore the laws of
physics in a fun way there are
interactive courses on everything from
algebra to algorithm fundamentals you
never have to stress out about tests and
brilliant is for all skill levels you
can simply pick a course and get started
if you're feeling stuck and don't
understand you can learn at your own
pace by reading the explanations again
it's free to sign up for brilliant if
you use the link in my description
brilliant.org newsthink and the first
200 people who use my link will get 20
off the premium subscription which gives
you unlimited access to all of the
course offerings thanks for watching for
news think i'm cindy palm
[Music]